let's get back into this I wanna tell
you a couple of things about this I want
to reintroduce the idea afterwards
they're just another way to think about
it an important distinction and then
tell you a couple things about how to
show these things so the best way the
most accurate way to understand what
identities are is to compare them to
something you already know about
okay so underneath this image would you
write for me these two or three things
because putting them in this context I
hope will help you understand what
identities are and what they are not so
expressions and equations we've met
these a long time ago in fact even as
early as RG ya u 7 you solving equations
and you know anyway expressions are and
how to collect like terms blah blah blah
so what's an expression an expression is
just a collection of terms that's all it
is so for example you could say X x
squared hey guys
that's an expression okay significantly
it's not an equation because it's
missing what it's missing an equality
sign right and equals something okay
so I could say an equation which would
be similar to this is x squared who's 9
right
so it has the expression in it but then
it's saying it equals something else and
then you can solve it right so you may
remember you can simplify expressions
but you can only solve equations we
can't solve an expression it's not equal
to anything okay so this is like if you
want to think about in grammar terms
this is like a word and this is like a
statement okay this is saying something
is equal to something else
okay now identities are different again
it's a bit tricky because we tend to I
think partly because we're lazy we use
the same notation for identities that we
do for equations but actually there's a
slightly different term you should use
so let me give you an example here's
here's something
now a couple of things the first thing
you'll notice is that this equation
cannot be solved partly because it's not
an equation see that yep we would
usually write an identity like the way
you've been writing your tree okay this
is just with an equal sign okay but this
like you're used to this in the context
of like triangles and like anything we
associate this with colons right now
Congress is a good thing to connected to
because when you've got two triangles
and we say these two triangles are
congruent we mean that they are
identical in every possible way same
shape same size everything about them is
the same and that's the same thing that
we have here right so I read this as in
this context Audrina has is identical to
okay as opposed to is equal to right now
well let's let's get at this another way
okay this is an expression expressions
cannot be true or false okay because
it's just it's just a word that's out
there okay an equation an equation is
only true sometimes right it's true I
should say for it's true for certain
values of X and it's not true for other
values okay
for instance this equation is only true
for x equals plus or minus 3 but if x
equals 2 it's not true it's a lie here
right it's only talking about very
specific X so this is true for certain
values of X it's true sometimes this
though you can throw any X you like in
there and both sides will always be
identical so this is not true for
certain values of X this is true for all
real values of X ok you can throw
anything you like any day this is true
sometimes but this is true always ok so
let me give you a really cheesy way to
remember this super cheesy but I promise
you'll remember ok expressions equations
identities let's put this all in English
so an expression would be a word like
say cool that's just a word it doesn't
mean anything on a statement like it
can't be true or false it's just a word
okay I could extend this and say my car
is cool right that's a statement of
equality right except it's only true
some of the time right the aircon in my
car is terrible
so it's only true if we're taught
basically and all other times of the
year it is not true okay so this is true
sometimes right this statement
well let's see how that fit this is true
all the time no exceptions
okay doesn't matter where you are what
time of the year it is I told you it was
cheesy okay so so do you see how these
scaffold up on each other
okay well we do see some sequences
there's a similar kind of idea of these
concepts which build on each other and
they're very very different and it's
easy to sort of get them confused